some families are still looking for
their children who attended last night's
concert one mother Charlotte Campbell
spoke to British TV about her daughter
Olivia I run downstairs and put the news
on transcold of Olivia couldn't get all
of her there was many phone calls then
from the police they weren't really
helpful at that time because it was so
fresh rock at the moment because I don't
know where she is I don't know she's
alive even yet just trying every social
media site going we're constantly
ringing her phone but it's just going
straight through so it cannot be
connected at the moment she was with a
friend from school he's been found he is
in hospital he's with his family
everything every possible scenario that
she's just gonna walk through this door
any minute like she's not even known
what's going on that she's in a hospital
somewhere one in May but no one can get
hold of me because they don't know she
is oh that she's dead wait that's what I
think guys is the hardest part of this
story to not know what happened if
they're okay where are they
I talked to Scooter Braun this morning
at 1:30 this morning who's ariana
grande's manager and I asked how she was
doing he said she's not good at all
she's hysterical in fact none of us are
she's devastated and they weren't sure
what they were gonna do now with their
tunes of the future because she's right
in the middle of the tour very very sad
situation for those parents it's that
unimaginable worry yeah about where is
her daughter and I think she's needed
and many of these kids as you know nor
were young little girls many of them
their first time concert I can't stop
thinking about that either